it's the story that never ends is Tom
Brady his appeal denied rejected Mike
Florio from profootballtalk enough to
join us what's this ruling mean Mike
well here's what it means Tom Brady's
running out of options and he's down to
one additional court damn that he can go
to the US Supreme Court and the US
Supreme Court takes up a small fraction
of the cases presented to it every year
the first step would be to file a
request for the Supreme Court to even
take up the case convinced them to take
up the case and in the interim here's
where the action is going to be Tom
Brady would file a request to have his
suspension stayed while the US Supreme
Court decides whether or not take up the
case and the key person in deciding that
request would be Justice Ruth Bader
Ginsburg who is assigned to the cases
arising from the Second Circuit she is
the one who will decide whether or not
Tom Brady's suspension will be put on
hold while the Supreme Court decides
whether not take up the case so whether
or not he plays week one Sunday night
NBC in Arizona Justice Ruth Bader
Ginsburg is likely going to be the
person who decides that best guess is
Brady de starting quarterback opening
night I think he will be now here's
where it gets very interesting and also
very political Justice Ruth Bader
Ginsburg based upon her background and
her ideology she would be naturally
inclined I think to stay this but
there's a complication and yes it all
leads back to Donald Trump Tom Brady is
a self-professed friend of Donald Trump
and earlier this week Justice Ginsburg
just flat-out lamb basted Trump calling
him a faker and all sorts of other
things and those political elements can
work their way into cases where they
shouldn't and I'd I'm very interested to
see whether to what extent Brady's
friendship of Trump actually hurts him
in front of Justice Ginsburg well taken
to another level there might well but
that you know but that you know we we
all know that that what meets the eye is
rarely what makes the decisions and
there's always stuff happening behind
the scenes and with Trump out there and
Brady making it clear
that he and Trump our friends and
Ginsberg making it clear that she has no
regard for Trump that how can that not
be an issue with some level in this case
another quarterback Ryan Fitzpatrick on
the outside looking in who wins this
game of who blinks first well
deadline-driven business so we keep our
eyes on the start of training camp and
they should be able to get something
done by them but they should have done
something by now you need to have your
starting quarterback around for the
offseason program you need to work on
timing you need to work on any changes
to the office and I you know the Jets
have been very stubborn about what
they're going to pay Fitzpatrick because
no one else is willing to pay him
anything close to that well the fact
that no one else wants him doesn't
change the fact that the Jets needed and
the Jets maybe are willing to go forward
with Geno Smith they had an article on
the team website earlier this week
touting how Geno Smith has had the game
slow down for him and maybe now I
remember last year before I can in poly
broke Geno Smith's jaw he was the number
one in Fitzpatrick was the number two so
maybe the Jets know something the rest
of us don't I think if they don't get it
done though by training camp opening
they just need to shake hands and thank
each other and move on because if I'm a
Jets fan this uncertainties driving me
crazy thank you Mike all right buddy
that's Mike Florio profootballtalk on
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience